one of the world's most instagramed
properties is at the center of a unique
conservation effort it's known as
Giraffe Manor and its mission is to help
save the Majestic giraffe from the
threat of Extinction poaching and
drought mean that the species has
already disappeared in seven African
countries Deborah Pata takes us to
Nairobi to see how tourism is helping
these towering creatures survive
it just wouldn't feel like Africa
without them no Wildlife Safari is
complete without a sighting of these
gentle Giants of the Savannah
and Kenya's Giraffe Manor does one
better eco-tourists pay for the chance
to get up close and personal
as bucket list experiences go this is
remarkable
but it's also very very important for
conservation
environmentalist Cecilia mueni says
people have no idea giraffes are
fighting for their survival the giraffe
is basically under threat from all
corners from people themselves from
predators from climate change poachers
hunt them for bush meat and even their
tails believing it gives them power
humans encroach on giraffe habitat and
exacerbating all of this the Horn of
Africa's worst drought in 40 years
captured in these horrific images
numbers of the Nubian giraffe have
dwindled to such an extent they're on
the critically endangered list action is
needed says conservationist Arthur
muneza and if we don't act now we don't
act now we might lose them and this has
happened actually in the last 30 to 40
years where we've where giraffe have
gone extinct in at least seven African
countries
privilege helps reverse that devastating
trend
such a surreal experience
a giraffe sticking its head through a
window
guests wake up to an unusual greeting
and share a very different kind of meal
look who has come for breakfast
The Experience exceeded American visitor
Shannon Turner's expectations this place
is mind-blowing and all of the things
that it does and I'm finding out you
know I mean the way that me just being
here gives back to make it be even it's
just made the experience even greater
the animals come over for high tea and
breakfast but live next door at the
giraffe Center where they Stoke a
passion for wildlife in the very young
who visit for free
tourism funds this conservation and
supports a breeding program run by both
the center and the manor together with
the Kenyan government most of the
giraffe born here have been reintroduced
into the wild it is so successful
numbers have risen from just 76 to 1200
over the past 40 years
oh once in a lifetime experience that is
Saving Lives as well for CBS mornings
Deborah Patcher Nairobi Kenya
I had followed this place on Instagram
and I have been dying to go yes it looks
incredible it is incredible and I
sometimes Marvel at a world where we
could see our children not know these
animals not no giraffes or polar bears
or Tigers because they are in danger of
being extinct and obviously those
animals are spread out in different
parts of the world but when you think
about these majestic creatures that are
in danger of being extinct you applaud
the efforts of people you haven't been
to that particular conservation but
you've done something similar I've been
I've been on Safari uh in South Africa
it is an experience of a lifetime I
recommend it if you can do it you should
try to do it because I gotta go I'm
gonna get your info